good morning to you chancellor let's
start should we were john ended up um
are you going to cut good morning are
you going to cut taxes before the next
election let's just go with a yes or no
well we started cutting taxes yesterday
okay our priority being those on the
lowest incomes it's a tax cut for two
million families and it's not going to
come in until well it's not going to
come in as normal next april it's going
to come in a few weeks time so we can
get help to people right now but as i
said very clearly yesterday my ambition
is to lower taxes for people that's what
i would like to do as chancellor we had
to take some corrective action as a
result of the crisis and the response we
took to it but you know hopefully that
now is done and as we demonstrated
yesterday our priority is to make sure
that work pays we reward people's
efforts and i'm delighted that we could
make a start on that yesterday okay will
there be income tax cuts before the next
election go on go with yes or no
no no no okay we'll just let's talk
about this budget rather than all the
other ones
well this is what a lot of people have
been asking and certainly a lot of uh
tory back ventures want to know the
answer to that so asking for a friend
well they i i spend time with them
myself actually but look i think i i
made a very clear uh demonstration of
our intent yesterday and i think it's
important to remember why are we in this
position a year ago we outlined our plan
for jobs at a time when people think
well they feared the worst and because
of the plan that we put in place which
the independent forecaster yesterday
described as remarkably successful we've
managed to ensure that economic growth
is recovering the economy is growing
well many more people in work
unemployment is far lower than feared
and because of that yesterday we had a
budget that will deliver a stronger
economy for the british people so
stronger public services investment in
our future growth backing businesses
much like the ones i'm surrounded by
today but also supporting working
families by freezing fuel duty and
cutting taxes on the lowest paid but we
were able to do all of that because of
the action that we took last year
okay highest tax rate since the 1950s
inflation potentially up to five percent
interest rates potentially three and a
half percent you made no apology for any
of that that's all common knowledge
national insurance of course going up in
april as well
how much more will you personally be uh
paying with your national insurance do
you know
yeah well the the thing about national
insurance is it's a progressive tax and
it's been described as such by all of
the various commentators uh when it was
outlined but as you said the tax burden
as i said yesterday i'm uncomfortable
with it where it is and i'd like to see
taxes come down on people which is why
we took a first step on that yesterday
and with a grant of inflation that's
absolutely right that's one of the many
challenges that i have to grapple with
as a chancellor i explained yesterday to
provide hopefully some reassurance of
the country that the bulk of the
inflation we're seeing as a result of
two global forces one economy's
reopening and supply chains being uh
under pressure and secondly energy
prices now i don't have a magic wand and
it'll be irresponsible of me to stand
here and tell you i can make those
global problems disappear overnight i
can't but where the government can take
action to help with the cost of living
whether it's through things like
freezing fuel duty or cutting taxes for
the lowest paid or indeed things like
investing in lorry park facilities which
the transport secretary announced
yesterday to help attract people into
that profession where we can make a
difference of course we will
okay back to the question um we've made
a calculation that your national
insurance will be eight and a half
thousand pounds uh given your salary of
148 thousand pounds as the as the
chancellor um you know given that you
earn a good salary and given that you
did very well in the city and you know
you have um you you're very comfortably
off do you feel that that is enough of a
contribution by you
[Music]
i think national insurance is a
progressive way to raise money the top
14
of income earners on national insurance
end up contributing over half of all the
sums raised from that uh tax rise so i
think actually it is a progressive way
to raise money those with the broadest
shoulders will carry more of the burden
of and it's important to remember what
was that for that was money for the nhs
our number one priority to help the nhs
recover and make a start on tackling the
the significant backlogs that have built
up during the crisis and to implement
the prime minister's landmark reforms to
social care something that any other
governments have not been able to
achieve so that that's what that one is
therefore there's no easy way to raise
tax there's no perfect way to do it it's
it's not my question though chancellor
you
know
the question is is there a better way
but it's you know it's always vulgar if
you think that's something
of course
i can talk money with the chancellor can
i not if i can't talk money with the
chancellor then who can i you're worth
tens of millions of pounds
if you are paying eight and a half
thousand pounds in national insurance
and you've got a very very healthy bank
balance do you think that is fair do you
think that is leveling up
i think i think what leveling up is is
i'm standing here in the world famous
berry market which yesterday received 20
million pounds from our leveling up fund
to improve the market create new jobs
and ensure that places like berry c
investment that's leveling up in
practice making sure people's
communities are fantastic places to live
leveling up is about spreading
opportunity around the country making
sure that wherever people are they have
the skills the opportunities to train
but those are the kinds of things that
leveling up means and with regard to
making sure that we help everyone
yesterday we cut taxes for two million
of the lowest paid people in the country
so that is a very clear statement of
both my values the government's values
and our desire to help those who
absolutely need our help the most so i'm
going to take that as yes you think
eight and a half grand is enough on your
salary and wealth at the ifs though
given what you've just been saying they
say living standards will stagnate for
people who've had a really hard time and
that's because of the higher taxes from
what you're saying you disagree with the
ifs
well i think i'd look at the measures
that we put in place as we've just
talked about a tax cut for
two million of the lowest paid people in
our country and i think your report was
showing so a single mother with two kids
who's renting will be better off by
about 1 200 pounds a year a couple where
someone is working full time and someone
is working part-time on the national
living wage with two kids renting will
be 1 800 pounds a year better off the
national living wage went up yesterday
to 9 pounds 50 and that will mean a
thousand pounds more for someone who's
working full-time on the national living
wage so there are lots of things we are
doing that will help people keep more of
their money ensure that they can earn
more and keep the cost of living down
for example the ifs says that living
standards will stagnate do you disagree
well actually coming into this crisis
other think tanks said we were enjoying
a mini living standards boom and real
household disposable income was
increasing at a reasonably rapid rate
and people will look at the measures
that we've announced whether it's
freezing fuel duty cutting taxes for
millions of the lowest paid
the national living wage going up all
the investment we're putting into
people's skills to make sure that they
can get retraining or learn new things
that will help them earn more those are
all the types of things we can do to
raise the living standards and i'm
confident that over the next few months
and years just as we have over the last
12 months seen success in our economic
plans we will continue to see that
success going forward okay let me ask
you about the climate then instead
fuel duty
frozen again
passenger duty reduced for uh national
travel um do you not care about the
environment
oh hang on kay just a minute ago you
were asking me about living standards
for people and the cost of living and
and now you're upset that we're freezing
fuel duty or making it cheaper on
what i'm doing is asking you whether you
don't care about it with fuel prices
yeah well
well we just talked about this and with
fuel prices at almost a decade high i
didn't think it was the right thing to
do to add to people's costs by
increasing fuel duty and with regard to
air passenger duty i think what you
didn't mention is we also are
introducing a new band for ultra
long-haul flights so that those who fly
the furthest to places like japan or
chile will see a higher rate of air
passenger duty not much of a higher rate
to be fair chancellor not much of a
higher rate and at the same time well
actually if you look at if you look at
the impact on carbon the the overall uh
i think view from the independent
forecast yesterday was taken in totality
with the measures that we are taking put
us further along the path to net zero
and reduce climate emissions okay and
that's just one of the things we're
doing we're also investing money in
creating what are called sustainable
aviation fuel plants in the uk and
passion of the prime ministers to find
you know a new form of aviation fuel
that's more sustainable that was all
outlined last week in the net zero
strategy and it's important to remember
that aviation in general accounts for i
think just about eight percent of our
emissions and uh the domestic bit of
that which you referred to at the
beginning is about four percent of the
eight percent so obviously this is a
small amount
okay your your opposite number rachel
reeves saying at least bankers and short
haul flights on short haul flights so it
will be cheering with champagne um so
that's their view on that i'll put it to
uh in the next hour i suppose cop is all
about action though isn't it not in 2050
but now so why
are you uh instead benefiting motorists
and people who are on short haul flights
rather than worrying about emissions
well i we do worry about missions and
that's why last week we outlined a
comprehensive net zero strategy the
prime minister put that out there it's i
think widely been considered one of the
most comprehensive plans of any
government anywhere in the world it was
backed up with 30 billion pounds of
investment across the board in areas
like offshore wind nuclear hydrogen
carbon capture and storage the
electrification of our car fleet as you
as you rightly mentioned all those
things are covered in it so we're very
clearly incredibly on a path to net zero
but i just pick up on one thing i think
you said my labour opposite number was
upset that we were going to cut the duty
on sparkling wine and champagne i'm not
going to make any apologies for that we
have an irrational system at the moment
of how we tax alcohol the new system
we're going to bring in into place it's
going to be simpler it's going to be
fairer and it's going to be healthier
and it's going to support pubs and i
know many people enjoy whether it's a
bottle of prosecco to celebrate
something we've seen sparkling wine
sales in the country double in just the
last five years fueled by actually
bottles of prosecco that may cost seven
pounds or so and the price of those
bottles will come down by about 87 p and
i think that's a good thing actually
because everyone when something good
happens wants to celebrate with a bit of
bubbly and we're actually going to
remove the completely irrational duty
premium that those drinks currently bear
they're no more alcoholic than still
wine but yet they pay a lot more duty
that seems to me to be unfair and silly
and i'd like to be able to sort that out
celebrating with champagne maybe not
those that are struggling to feed their
kids but that's that's perhaps for
another day uh carbon emissions is that
the best place for you to be this
morning well actually
on that point
if i could ask the question because
we're almost out of time you are at a
meat market today why are you in a meat
market when we're told to eat less meat
to try and cut down on carbon emissions
i i i mean i i'm not telling anyone uh
to eat less meat and and you mentioned
children actually yesterday's budget
confirmed 200 million pounds a year for
the holiday activity and food program
which is a new program that this
government has introduced to provide
enriching activities and meals for
children outside of term time that was
something the spending review yesterday
confirmed as well as actually lots of
investment to help young families and
especially new parents
who are struggling with various things
because it's something that we believe
is important uh those early days in
children's lives and young parents lives
are really important and as a result of
the actions we took yesterday we're
going to be able to do more to support
them which i think is you're not you're
not telling people to eat less meat but
your chief scientific advisor is to try
and cut down on carbon emissions
there's lots of different ways that we
can tackle climate change and last week
the prime minister outlined the net zero
strategy i don't think there was
anything
about that in there but what there was
was the green industrial revolution as
he would describe it with investment to
catalyze the industries of the future to
help us make the transition and in the
process create lots of jobs and and
that's exactly what we're trying to do
i like to think i made it took a small
role in you finally getting your dog how
is the dog
yes yes yes you did the dog she's she's
great thank you growing quickly and uh
and a handful so but she'll start
needing some proper runs soon so you
might see me out about and the kids are
thrilled i'm guessing she's good i'm
looking forward to spending yeah they
are they are thrilled doing more to help
finally which is also good and i'm
looking forward to actually spending a
bit more time with her now that i've got
this budget out of the way
fantastic we'll see you at cop26 next
week thanks a lot chancellor
see you next week okay thank you thank
you